ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER PORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD THE
RAZA EGGMAN LASER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO.
JONES FROM LAGER LAYERED LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MAN NEWMAN
NIELSEN PHOTO OF BOTH HAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN. NUMBER BY CASKEY WIENER
WILK.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND WELCOME OUR
NEWEST SENATOR SENATOR COM
LONGER. ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME OUR SPECIAL GUEST
FOR TODAY'S SESSION LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR THE LADY GONNA LAKIS.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR RUBIO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR GROWTH. SENATOR
RUBIO. IN LOVING GOD. WE PRAY
IN THE SPIRIT OF SYMPATRIC. WE
ARRIVED TODAY THROUGH THE
STRENGTH OF HAVE IN. LIGHT OF
THE SUN SPLENDOR FIRE SPEED OF
LIGHTNING SWIFTNESS OF THE
LEND. DEPTH OF THE SEA.
STABILITY OF THE EARTH.
FIRMNESS OF THE ROCK. WE
ARRIVED TODAY- GOT STRAINED TO
PILOT US. GOD'S MIGHT TO UPHOLD
US. GOD'S WISDOM TO GUIDE US
BUT I TO LET BEFORE US. GOTS
HERE TO HEAR US GOD'S WORD TO
SPEAK FOR US. THAT'S HAND TO
GUARD US. GOD'S WAY TO LIE
BEFORE US GOTH'S SHIELD TO
PROTECT US. BOTS HOST TO SAVE
US A FAR IN A NEAR. ALONE OR IN
MULTITUDE. MAY GOD'S SPIRIT
SITE. IN THE HEART OF EVERYONE
WHO THINKS OF US. MAY GOD SPEAK
THROUGH THE MOUTH OF EVERYONE
WHO SPEAKS OF US. WE ARRIVED
TODAY THROUGH THE MIGHTY
STREAM. OF THE LORD. OF
CREATION AMEN. MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR
NATION'S FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. YOU WILL. THIS IS.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR
LA MON PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR LIMóN
WELCOME MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR WILL PROVIDE REMARKS.
RELATIVE TO TODAY'S SESSION.
MADAM LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS I AM PROUD
AND HONORED TO JOIN YOU TODAY
AS WE COMMEMORATE WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH CELEBRATE THE
INCREDIBLE WOMEN LEADERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND HONOR
THE MEMORY OF THE GREAT RUTH
PATER GINSBURG. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A TRAILBLAZER IN
THE FIGHT FOR REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN FROM SMALL AND BIG CITY
MAYORS TO MEMBERS AND LEADERS
OF OUR STATE LEGISLATURE TO THE
U. S. HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
AND THE U. S. SENATE. AND NOW
THE VICE PRESIDENCY OF THE
UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA WOMEN
LEAD THE WAY. IN SO MANY WAYS
WE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT WOMEN
BELONG AT THE TABLE THAT OUR
VOICES COUNT AND THAT OUR
LEADERSHIP IS FAIR JUST
EFFECTIVE AND INSPIRING. IT'S
TRUE NOT ONLY IN GOVERNMENT BUT
IN ALL SECTORS OF CIVIC AND
BUSINESS LEADERSHIP AS WELL.
THIS BODY MADE THAT CLEAR WHEN
IT VOTED TO APPROVE LEGISLATION
TO REQUIRE MORE WOMEN ON
CORPORATE BOARDS THAT
LEGISLATION IS NOW LAW THANKS
TO FORMER SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON HERSELF NOW AN ICONIC
AND HISTORIC LEADER. AND EACH
YEAR THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
FINDS MORE WAYS TO MAKE OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR STATE MORE
EQUITABLE. THIS YEAR I'M
EXCITED TO SPONSOR THE GENDER
EQUITY IN LEADERSHIP PACKED IN
THE ASSEMBLY TO UPDATE OUR MALE
PRONOUN HEAVY GOVERNMENT COAT.
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA LAW AS
IT CURRENTLY EXISTS THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS ALWAYS
DEFINED AS HE HE- I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT ANOTHER MEASURE HERE IN
THE SENATE TO CORRECT SIMILARLY
GENDERED CODE SECTIONS ABOUT
THE CHP COMMISSIONER WHO AS YOU
ALL KNOW IS NOW COMMISSIONER
AMANDA READ. ALSO A WOMAN AND
AN EXTRAORDINARY ONE AT THAT.
COMMISSIONER RAY AND I MAY BE
THE FIRST WOMEN IN OUR
RESPECTIVE POSITIONS BUT TO
BORROW A LINE FROM VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS WE MAY BE THE
FIRST BUT WE WON'T BE THE LAST
THROUGH CHANGING THE GOVERNMENT
CODE TO REFLECT THIS FACT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL HAPPEN THIS
YEAR I HOPE. I'M ALSO VERY
PROUD TO BE HERE AS YOU
PROCLAIM MARCH FIFTEENTH
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
DAY. RBG WAS IT TOWERING FIGURE
A GREAT WARRIOR FOR WOMEN
JUSTICE AND DEMOCRACY YOUR
ACTION TODAY WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT SHE WILL SERVE AS AN
INDURAIN SYMBOL OF HOPE AND
STRENGTH FOR WOMEN. AND FOR ALL
PEOPLE SEEKING A FAIRER MORE
EQUITABLE WORLD. WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED MUCH BUT MUCH
REMAINS TO BE DONE. S. RBG ONCE
SAID REAL CHANGE IN DURING
CHANGE HAPPENS ONE STEP AT A
TIME. I'M PROUD TO STAND WITH
YOU AS WE CONTINUE TO ADVANCE
THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN AND EQUAL
RIGHTS FOR ALL HERE IN THE
BEAUTIFUL STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR CAN LOCK US OF OUR
GREAT WORDS FOR TODAY MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO SENATE THIRD READING FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN S. R. FIFTEEN
SENATOR SKINNER ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THIS ITEM. YES
I AM PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY- MANCINELLI PLENARY.
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. S.
R. FIFTEEN FOR CLAIMS MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH. AND THIS MONTH
WE PAY TRIBUTE TO WOMEN ALL
WOMEN BUT WOMEN HAVE BEEN
CONTRIBUTING TO THE ECONOMIC
SOCIAL AND CULTURAL VITALITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE U. S. IN THE
WORLD FOR GENERATIONS. WHO ARE
ON SONG AND I'M RECOGNIZED AND
TOO FREQUENTLY ABSENT FROM OUR
HISTORY BOOKS. WE ESPECIALLY
HONOR THOSE WOMEN WHO CAME
BEFORE ON ON WHOSE SHOULDERS WE
STAND. I KNOW I WILL TAKE THE
LIBERTY FROM OUR COLLEAGUE
SENATOR FROM GARDENIA WHO GAVE
US SO MANY FIRSTS WHEN HE WAS
DOING BLACK HISTORY MONTH SO.
IRAQ'S THE CUP OF COFFEE YOU
PROBABLY DURING THIS FIRST
MORNING OF THE CLOCKS MOVING
FORWARD YOU CAN THANK THE
LEADER PENS WHO INVENTED THE
COFFEE FILTER. THAT IS WE USE
THE INTERNET TO HOLD YOU
MEETINGS THANK YOU LAMAR WHO
DURING WORLD WAR TWO DEVELOPED
EARLY WIFI TO PREVENT TORPEDOES
FROM BEING. TEMPTED SHE ALSO
FILED THE FIRST PATENTS FOR GPS
AND BLUETOOTH. THAT IS WE GET
OUR VACCINATIONS WHICH WERE
DEVELOPED BASED ON DNA SCIENCE
WE CAN THAK ROSALIND FRANKLIN
NOT WATSON AND CRICK FOR THE
DOUBLE HELIX. BADLY TEACHER
GREER WHO INVENTED THE MEDICAL.
SYRINGE IN EIGHTEEN NINETY
NINE. AND AS WE JUGGLE RISK. AT
HOME DURING THIS PANDEMIC. WE
CAN CERTAINLY BE THANKFUL TO
JOSEPHINE COCHRAN FOR INVENTING
THE DISHWASHER. CALLER ID AND
CALL WAITING WERE INVENTED IN
THE SEVENTIES BY SHIRLEY ANN
JACKSON WHO IS THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN TO GET A PHD FROM. MIT
AND IF YOU THINK ALL HIGH
ROLLERS ARE MEN THEN YOU'VE
MISSED THE FACT THAT OUR
FAVORITE BOARD GAME MONOPOLY
WAS INVENTED BY ELIZABETH
MACKEY. SO HERE IN THE STATE
SENATE SEVERAL OF OUR OWN HAVE
BROKEN GLASS CEILINGS FOR
EXAMPLE. I AM THE ONLY SENATOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF ANY PARTY TO
A BROKEN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
VOTES. SENATE PRO TEM ATKINS IS
THE FIRST WOMAN. AND THE FIRST
OPENLY LGBT PERSON TO LEAD THE
STATE SENATE AS WELL AS THE
FIRST SPEAKER TO BECOME THE
SENATE PRO TEM. SENATOR
PATRICIA BATES WAS THE FIRST
FEMALE AN OVERALL MAYOR OF
LAGUNA NIGEL AFTER SPEARHEADING
THE INCORPORATION OF THE CITY
AND A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
REPUBLICAN WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
SENATOR ANNA CABALLERO THE
FIRST FEMALE MAYOR OF SALINAS
AND THE HIGHEST RANKING LATINA
IN STATE GOVERNMENT WHEN SHE
WAS APPOINTED. BY GOVERNOR
BROWN TO SECRETARY BUSINESS
SENATOR MARIA ELENA DURAZO THE
FIRST FEMALE SECRETARY
TREASURER OF LA COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR THE SECOND
LARGEST LABOR COUNCIL IN THE
COUNTRY. SENATOR SUSAN EGGMAN
THE FIRST LATINA TO SERVE
SENATE DISTRICT FIVE AND THE
FIRST OPENLY LGBTQ ARTIST
WITHIN AND STATE SENATE.
SENATOR SANTANA GROWTH FOR THE
FIRST FEMALE VETERANS ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
SENATOR ELENA GONZALEZ THE
FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR TO LEAD
SENATE TRANSPORTATION SENATOR
MELISSA HURTADO THE YOUNGEST
WOMAN EVER ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. AND
OUR SENATORS COM LARGER FIRST
WOMAN TO WIN BOTH THE FOR
ELECTIONS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE BY SPECIAL ELECTION.
SENATOR CONNIE LEYVA FIRST
FEMALE PRESIDENT OF THE STATE
WIDE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION SENATOR MONIQUE
LIMON THE FIRST LATINO TO SERVE
IN THE NINETEENTH SENATE
DISTRICT. SENATOR MELISSA
MELENDEZ ONE OF THE FIRST WOMEN
APPROVED TO FLY ABOARD IN EP
THREE RUN ACROSS RECONNAISSANCE
AIRCRAFT OVERSEAS SENATOR
ROSALIE C. BUT CHAIR BOB FIRST
REPUBLICAN WOMAN TO SERVE THE
TWENTY THIRD SENATE DISTRICT
SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO. FIRSTLY
CHEN LATINO CHAIR OF THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE. IN WITH
OUR- FEMALE. FIRST FEMALE VICE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA'S. BONE
KAMALA HARRIS. WHO IS WE ARE.
NOT ON THE DOORS OF THE WHITE
HOUSE. AND PETER GINSBERG WHO'S
EIGHTY EIGHTH BIRTHDAY WE
CELEBRATE TODAY. WE CAN THANK
FOR HER LANDMARK CASE WHICH
STOPPED DISCRIMINATION ON THE
BASIS OF SEX. SO ALL OF THESE
WOMEN I MENTIONED. I'VE MADE
GREAT CRACKS IN THE GLASS
CEILING HOWEVER THERE IS MUCH
WORK WE STILL MUST DO TO LIFT
WOMEN UP TO ACHIEVE GENDER
EQUITY IN PAY. AND IN THE ROLES
OF POWER IN BUSINESS AND
GOVERNMENT AS EXAMPLE RIGHT
HERE IN OUR OWN STATE
LEGISLATURE ONLY THIRTY SEVEN.
OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MEMBERS
ARE WOMEN. WE STILL HAVE TO DO
MUCH TO HAVE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT TAKEN SERIOUSLY. TO
HAVE OUR WOMEN'S WORK GIVEN THE
APPROPRIATE ECONOMIC VALUE.
WHEN WE SEE THAT THE LOWEST
PAID JOB CATEGORIES CONTINUE TO
BE FEMALE DOMINATED TEACHERS
CHILD CARE WORKERS THOSE CARING
FOR SENIORS AND MANY MANY
OTHERS IN THE SERVICE SECTOR.
EVEN WHILE WE KNOW. THAT THOSE
JOBS ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF A VIBRANT
ECONOMY WITHOUT WHICH WE WOULD
NOT HAVE A HEALTHY ECONOMY. SO
WE KNOW THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
WORK TO BE DONE. AND WHAT ABOUT
OUR REFUSAL TO RECOGNIZE THE
ECONOMIC VALUE OF WOMEN'S
UNPAID DOMESTIC LABOR. THE CARE
AND RESPONSIBILITY THAT IS
GIVEN TO CHILDREN TO SENIORS
AND DISABLED IN THAT WOMAN'S
HOUSEHOLD OR FOR THE HOUSEHOLD
MANAGEMENT UPKEEP IN OTHER
TASKS. THAT WOMEN TAKE ON AND
FOR WHICH OUR ECONOMIES
ABSOLUTELY DEPEND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN KANARIS ESTIMATED THAT
IF AMERICAN WOMEN HAD BEEN
AMERICAN WOMEN. HAD BEEN PAID
MINIMUM WAGE FOR THE- HOURS
UNPAID WORK THAT THEY DID
AROUND. THE HOUSE IN CARING FOR
RELATIVES. WE WANTED WOULD HAVE
MADE ONE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLARS. BUT WE DO NOT TAKE
STOCK OF THAT VALUE UNTIL THERE
IS A DISRUPTION IN SUPPLY. TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT POINT ON
OCTOBER TWENTY FOURTH 197590%
OF THE WOMEN RESIDENTS OF
ICELAND REFUSED TO COOK. TO
CLEAN TO LOOK AFTER CHILDREN TO
DO ANY OF THE OTHER NORMAL WORK
THAT WOMEN ARE TAKEN FOR
GRANTED TO DO. IT BROUGHT I
SLIMMED TO A STANDSTILL. IT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SCRAMBLE TO
FILL IN TAKING THEIR CHILDREN
TO WORK OVERWHELMING
RESTAURANTS YOU NAME IT THIS
PANDEMIC HAS CAUSED A DOUBLE
WHAMMY ON WOMEN. THOSE WHO ARE
PAID TO DO DOMESTIC LABOUR IN
LOW WAGE SERVICE JOBS CHILD
CARE AND OTHERS LOST THEIR JOBS
AND THAT URDEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY FELL ON
WOMEN OF COLOR. DURING THE
FIRST THREE MONTHS OF THE
DOWNTURN FOR EXAMPLE THE
EMPLOYMENT FOR BLACK AND LATINA
WOMEN FELL BY OVER TWENTY
PERCENT. IN DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR THE ENTIRE JOB LOSS WITH
WOMEN OF COLOR. WOMEN OF COLOR
LOST MORE THAN TWO TIMES THE
DECLINE OF UNEMPLOYMENT OF
EMPLOYMENT FOR WHITE WOMEN AND
MORE THAN THREE TIMES THE
DECLINE FOR MEN. AND THOSE THAT
DID NOT LOSE THEIR JOB AND THEY
PAID USUALLY RELIED ON OTHERS
THAT THEY PAID TO DO THAT WORK.
HOW TO DO IT THEMSELVES WHILE
STILL DOING THEIR OWN PAID JOBS
SO MANY OF THOSE WOMEN LEFT THE
WORK FORCE. CORONAVIRUS STOPPED
WOMEN IN THEIR TRACKS NOT ONLY
DID WE LOSE JOBS OR HAVE HOURS
CUT WE LEFT JOBS BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO ONE TO DO THAT UNPAID
DOMESTIC LABOR BUT US. SO
WOMEN'S ECONOMIC STATUS IN OUR
WORKPLACE EQUALITY WON'T HAVE
BEEN SET BACK DECADES BY THIS
CRISIS ON LAST WEEK THE STATE'S
LEADERS INTERVENE TO AVERT IT
AND AS POLICY MAKERS AND AS A
SOCIETY WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
TODAY WE REMEMBER AND CELEBRATE
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF WOMEN
AND WE COMMIT OURSELVES TO
BRING EQUITY IN ALL ASPECTS OF
LIFE TO THE WOMEN WHO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR STATE AND OUR
NATION GREAT. NOW EACH OF YOU
HAVE CHOSEN AN EXEMPLARY LEADER
FROM YOUR DISTRICT TO HONOR AS
YOU'RE A WOMAN OF THE YEAR.
WOMEN WHOSE HISTORY WILL BE
READ FOR GENERATIONS TO COME
WOMEN FROM EVERY WALK OF LIFE
FOR MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND THE
STATE SENATE HONORS AND HAS
DEEP GRATITUDE FOR ALL OF THE
WOMEN THAT YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUALLY CHOSEN TO HONOR WE
HAVE COMPILED THE COMMEMORATIVE
BOOKLET. OF YOUR AMAZING
STORIES OF THOSE WOMEN AS WELL
AS A GIFT BAG FOR YOUR HONOREE
THAT YOU CAN PICK UP ONE
SESSION HAS CONCLUDED TODAY. SO
I URGE ALL OF YOU TO TAKE THE
TIME TO READ THIS WOMAN'S
INCREDIBLE STORIES OF
ACHIEVEMENT AND SERVICE. AND I
HOPE THAT WE ALL COMMIT. TO
WORKING ON IN ACHIEVING THE
EQUITY THAT WOMEN SO DESERVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU- MATTER PRESIDENT- I RISE
TODAY IS- CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO SUPPORT S. R. FIFTEEN
ON WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH THIS
IS A MONTH LONG OBSERVANCE
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WOMEN THROUGHOUT HISTORY AND I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF ASIAN AMERICAN
WOMEN INDIVIDUALLY COLLECTIVELY
THAT BEEN MADE. TO THIS COUNTRY
WITH A LEGACY OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THESE WOMEN
EDUCATE INSPIRE US ALL OF US IN
THE UNITED STATES AD COUNTLESS
WOMEN ACROSS THE GLOBE. BUT IN
SUCH AS REPRESENT PATTY ME MEN.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR MAKE
BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR
ELECTED TO THE U. S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES. THROUGHOUT HER
POLITICAL CAREER- SHE FOUGHT
FOR EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WOMEN SHE WAS A KEY AUTHOR FOR
TITLE NINE THE LAW THE ENSURE
EQUAL FINANCING FOR WOMEN'S
ATHLETIC AND ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
IT CERTAINLY FUNDED
INSTITUTIONS. MAKE ALSO HELP
PASSED THE WOMEN'S EDUCATION
EQUITY ACT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH FUNDED PROGRAMS VOTE
GENDER EQUITY IN SCHOOLS TO
CREATE MORE EDUCATIONAL AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN AND TO
REMOVE SEXIST STEREOTYPES FROM
SCHOOL CURRICULA AND TEXTBOOKS.
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE DR CHAN
SUNG WOO WHO WAS A CHINESE
AMERICAN EXPERIMENTAL PHYSICIST
WHO MADE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE RESEARCH
OF READ RADIO ACTIVITY- WOUND
ROLLED AT ACTUALLY UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY WHERE SHE
COMPLETED HER PHD IN NINETEEN
FORTY. AFTER RECEIVING HER PHD
SHE TAUGHT PHYSICS AT PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY SMITH COLLEGE AND
BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN TO SERVE
AS PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
PHYSICAL SOCIETY NO ONE SEVERAL
AWARDS AND HONORS THROUGHOUT A
LIFETIME INCLUDING NATIONAL
MEDAL OF SCIENCE. INCOME STOCK
PRICE. WE ALSO REMEMBER.
KALPANA CHAWLA AN AMERICAN
ASTRONAUTS BECAME THE FIRST
WOMAN OF- INDIAN DESCENT TO
TRAVEL TO SPACE UNFORTUNATELY
CHAU AND SIX OTHER CREW MEMBERS
WERE TRAGICALLY KILLED WHEN THE
SPACE SHUTTLE COLUMBIA EXPLODED
DURING REENTRY CALLASPO'S
POSTHUMOUSLY AWARDED THE
CONGRESSIONAL SPACE MEDAL OF
HONOR AND SEVERAL SPEECH
UNIVERSITIES INSTITUTIONS HAVE
BEEN NAMED AFTER HONOR THIS IS
REGARDED AS A NATIONAL HERO AND
INDIA WHERE SHE WAS BORN IN
DISCIPLINE JOB. ALSO SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT AND MORE
RECENTLY- CHLOE'S OUT WAS THE
FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR NOMINATED
FOR AN OSCAR FOR BEST DIRECTOR-
THIS IS AFTER THE FIRST WOMAN
WAS ACTUALLY NOT NOMINATED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX SO. IT'S
AWESOME BEEN AROUND FOR SUCH A
LONG TIME YOU CAN TELL HOW FAR
BEHIND THEY ARE- ISA ALSO OF
COURSE CAN'T- PASS UP
MENTIONING OF COURSE ARE VERY
OWN- COMELEC HARRIS OF THE
FIRST ASIAN WOMAN TO BECOME.
AND BLACK GOING TO BE VICE
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES SO
I WON AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING UP S. R. FIFTEEN I
STAND WITH THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND HONORING THE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF WOMEN EVERY DAY. I THINK IS
THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT- THERE'S
STILL A LONG WAY TO GO BOTH FOR
WOMEN OVERALL AND SPECIALLY FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR AND TRYING TO
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO- TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE IN
OUR KNOWLEDGE ALSO OUR LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE OF THEIR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. ESPECIALLY US
WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN SENATOR DRAWS SO.
THANK YOU MATTER CHAIR. CHAIR
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS IT'S MY
HONOR TO RISE TODAY. IN SUPPORT
OF. S. R. FIFTEEN I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT SHE GAVE. OF THE
ROLE OF- OF WOMEN. ALTHOUGH THE
STRUGGLE CONTINUES FOR GENDER
PAY EQUITY THE FIGHT TO EARN A
LIVING WAGE AND INCREASED
WORKER PROTECTIONS. I AM
CONFIDENT WE WILL GET THERE
BECAUSE OF THE LEADERSHIP THAT
WE HAVE IN THE LEGISLATURE. AS
WELL AS THE DEDICATION OF THE
TALENT FOUND IN ART. EACH OF
OUR WOMEN OF THE YEAR HONOREES.
AS A COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SHOWN US HAS SHOWN US WOMEN.
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR
WERE MOST AFFECTED. BY JOB LOSS
WAGE THEFT AND DISPROPORTIONATE
HEALTH EFFECTS YET WE CONTINUE
TO PERSEVERE AND WE DO WHAT WE
CAN TO PROTECT AND PROVIDE FOR
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. YES THIS LAST YEAR
HAS BEEN TOUGH. BUT ALL OF YOU
ARE GREAT EXAMPLES OF WHAT HARD
WORK. DEDICATION AND
PERSEVERANCE CAN ACHIEVE.
THROUGH THE TOUGHEST OF TIMES
WE ARE RESILIENT WE ARE
COMPASSIONATE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE ARE STRONG THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
CENTER TERRAZZO SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR BRADFORD. PRESIDENT I
JUST QUICKLY RISE IN SUPPORT OF
S. R. FIFTEEN RECOGNIZING
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH. ASSURE
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING AWARENESS
TO MANY OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN
HAVE MADE TO THE STATE AND TO
THIS NATION- SINCE THE FOUNDING
OF THIS COUNTRY BLACK WOMEN'S
WORDS ACTIONS AND ACHIEVEMENTS
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO AMERICAN
SOCIETY CULTURE SUCCESS. AND
PROSPERITY. THROUGH HISTORY
OFTEN DISREGARDS THEIR
INVOLVEMENT BLACK WOMEN ARE.
MORE VITAL CONTRIBUTORS AND
LEADERS IN EVERY MOVEMENT FOR
SOCIAL CHANGE INCLUDING A FIVE
FORMATS A PATIENT. WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE CIVIL RIGHTS LBGT Q.
RIGHTS AMONG MANY OTHERS WOMEN
LIKE HARRIET TUBMAN SHIRLEY
CHISHOLM BARBARA JORDAN FANNIE
LOU HAMER. MARY MCLEOD BETHUNE.
BLACK WOMEN HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF DEMOCRACY
HISTORICALLY IN THIS COUNTRY
BUT WOMEN HAVE. HAVE AND
CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT WE ALL
CONSTRUCTED IN A MORE UNIFIED
SOCIETY. OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT WOMEN SHOULD NOT BE
IGNORED AND IT SHOULD BE
RECOGNISED JUST ONCE A MONTH
AND WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS EVERY YEAR AS
STATED A FEW WEEKS AGO- WE
OFTEN SAY IT'S A MAN'S WORLD
BUT BELIEVE ME A WOMAN MEXICO
AROUND A WOMAN MAKES IT WORK.
SO ON BEHALF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I SUPPORT S. R.
FIFTEEN NON FRIABLE THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN CENTERS CAN-
PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
AND- IN THE APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND AGAIN
THE REFERENCE TO PAY EQUITY
WHAT I FAILED TO MENTION IS FOR
EXAMPLE HEDY LAMARR. WITH THOSE
PATENTS I DESCRIBED DID NOT
RECEIVE ONE DINE NOT ONE DIME
FOR ANY OF HER DISCOVERIES
INVENTIONS OR PATENTS AND YOU
CAN LOOK THAT UP. SO WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO AND I ALSO
FAILED TO MENTION AT LEAST TWO
WOMEN ON THE SENATE FLOOR WHO
BROKEN SIGNIFICANT GLASS
CEILINGS THERE MAY BE VERY MANY
OTHER GLASS CEILING SAID SOME
OF OUR WOMEN ARE BROKEN BUT LET
ME AT LEAST GIVE THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. TO BERNIE
MCNULTY THE FIRST SENATE- CLERK
FOR FIRST FEMALE CLERK OF THE
SENATE AND TO ERICA CONTRARIS
THE FIRST WOMAN TO SERVE AS OUR
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE. AND
WITH THAT WE WILL STRIVE TO DO
MORE WILL START TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THERE'S NEVER
SITUATION WHERE I EVER HAVE TO
DESCRIBE A WOMAN'S FIRST
BECAUSE IT IS SO COMMON. AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
MAP SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BAKER. HI
FORGES AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO HI CORTESE I DALY
FIVE DODD. HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN.
HI GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH FIVE HERTZBERG HI HUESO
I HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S AYE MAN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN FIVE
CONTROL BOTH. I PAN HI
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER FIVE STERN AYE
NUMBER FIVE WACO SKI HI WIENER
FIVE WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE
DOES ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. CENTER
SKINNER. MEMBERS BY MOVED TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES AS
THEY RELATE TO ASSEMBLY BILLS
EIGHTY THREE AND EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER. MADAM%
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SKEWS ME CENTER NIELSEN GOING
TO GO AHEAD. VERY GOOD YES
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES I BAKER HI
FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE I OTHER
FIVE COURTESY I DALLY. DODD
FIVE THE RAZA HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE HUESO. HI TADO I
JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED FIVE
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN.
PHOTOBOOK PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI MY
CASTING HI WIENER. HI WILK.
FIVE THIRTY ONE NO ZERO THE
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
MARCH EIGHTEENTH THROUGH TWENTY
FOUR EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
REPORT FROM B. AND F. OUR
BUSINESS. MADAM PRESIDENT THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
RUBIO TO WHICH WERE REFERRED
ASSEMBLY BILLS EIGHTY THREE AND
EIGHTY EIGHT REPORTS THE SAME
BACK WITH A RECOMMENDATION TO
PASS NANCY SKINNER CHAIR ABOVE
BILLS ORDERED TO THIRD READING.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE ELEVEN SENATE BILL
TWO SIXTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL SIXTY
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY THE
SECOND READING WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MEMBERS YOU HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE BEING HANDED
OUT TO YOU WE WILL ACT ON THAT
IN A MOMENT WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. ITEMS
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
SENATOR BATES. FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN IF THE MICHAEL OKAY
ISLAND ITEM FOURTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF ERIC BERADA AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
PRIOR TO HIS ROLE MR HARADA WAS
SERVING AS THE DEPARTMENT'S
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR HE
STARTED HIS CAREER WITH ABC
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO AS AN
AGENT IN INGLEWOOD DISTRICT
OFFICE HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH TENTH
TWENTY UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
SENATOR GLAZERS SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF IT- KERALA AFTER
THIS POSITION I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY IS GEO CHAIR TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ALREADY WITH MR
HARADA IN MANY AREAS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC IT HE'S SHOWN A
REAL WILLINGNESS TO BE
FLEXIBLE. HERE TO WORK WELL
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY OF OUR SMALL
RESTAURANTS THAT HAVE BEEN- SO
BADLY HURT OVER THIS LAST YEAR
I THINK HE WOULD BODE WELL FOR
THE FUTURE OF ABC I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER DOT CENTER
GLAZER. THANK YOU AYE MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. IT'S BEEN A
VERY TOUGH HERE IN OUR STATE
FOR SO MANY. AND CERTAINLY FOR
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE ABC.
IT'S BEEN A PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING. WE KNOW THAT OUR
BUSINESSES THAT REY UPON
ALCOHOL SALES HAVE STRUGGLED IN
IN CHALLENGING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH
DIRECTOR HER UP HER OUT A- ON
SEVEN FOUR SPENT- MATTERS IN MY
DISTRICT THIS YEAR. AND I WANT
TO SAY THAT HE- HIS
PROFESSIONALISM. AND HIS
COMMUNICATION SKILLS. OF
SHARING WITH ME AND CONNECTING
WITH ME- THAT ON THESE MATTERS
WAS PARTICULARLY EXEMPLARY. AND
WITH THAT MEMBERS I THINK- HE'S
DESERVING OF OUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY AND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER MEMBERS CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHAUNA
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
A I TALKED TO RON- REGARDING
HIGH TODAY- I DO WANT TO FIRST
OF ALL COMMEND ABC- THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IN THE PREVIOUS.
DIRECTOR FOR ARE REALLY JUMPING
INTO ACTION WHEN THE PANDEMIC
TO. AND CREATING AN ENORMOUS
FLEXIBILITY FOR CITIES AND
RESTAURANTS AND BARS DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO HELP THEM SURVIVE.
WHETHER WITHOUT THE WORD-
SERVICE OF ALCOHOL OR OTHER
FLEXIBILITY IN THE RULES
WITHOUT WHICH MANY MORE
RESTAURANTS AND BARS WOULD
HAVE. PERMANENTLY GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS I HAVE ALREADY DNE SO
I REALLY REALLY WANT TO
RECOGNIZE- ABC. OR DOING THAT.
I WILL SAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH DIRECTOR RADHA.
GOING FORWARD TO LEARN. ALL THE
ALL THE WAY THING THAT AB C. D.
DURING THE KIND. AND THE PLUG.
THAT ABC PROVIDED IN THE SKY
DIDN'T FALL. AND IT SHOWED THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY DELEGATE MORE
DECISION MAKING TO OUR CITIES
TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AROUND
ALCOHOL AND IF YOU SEE DOES NOT
NEED TO BE. AS INVOLVED IN SUCH
A DETAILED HUESO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH DIRECTOR ON
THAT ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT A
LONG CONVERSATION WITH DIRECTOR
FRIDAY NIGHT IN RULES OF VOTED
TO SUPPORT HIS APPOINTMENT. AND
I'D LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS FROM SAN FRANCISCO. WE
HAVE SOMEONE IN THIS POSITION
THAT IS HAD APPROACHES THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION WE FIND
OURSELVES IN IN A WELL BALANCED
APPROACH. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE COMMUNITIES M. NEEDS ARE
MET ALONG WITH A EDUCATION
PROCESS TO. INDIVIDUALS THAT
OWN THESE BARS AND RESTAURANTS
THAT USE THIS- LICENSE. TO
SERVE ALCOHOL TO THEIR PATRONS
AND- THE LEADERSHIP THAT
DIRECTOR HARADA WILL PROVIDE
WILL TO HIS ENTIRE TEAM AS
EVIDENT TO WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO SAID AND
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IN
THE ERN COUNTY AREA. AND THE
TULARE COUNTY AREA HAS BEEN-
EXCEPTIONAL AND- ABC WITH IT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PANDEMIC SO
I WOULD URGE AND I BONUS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE MEMBERS SEEING NO FURTHER
DESCRIPTION HERTZBERG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MAN PRESIDENT I
JOIN WITH. MY COLLEAGUES IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE SENATOR
FROM BAKERSFIELD. WHO I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SITTING AT THE
RULES COMMITTEE WITH WITH
RESPECT TO THIS APPINTMENT.
THERE NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
LICENSES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THOSE LICENSES SUPPLY THE BIG
CODES INTO SMALL. MOM AND POP
SHOPS INTO THE CORNER BAR AND-
HAVE SO MUCH OF AN IMPACT ON
PEOPLE'S COMMUNITIES IN THE
LIKE AND WHY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME. WITH THIS-
APPOINTEE AND AM VERY PLEASED
BY HIS SKILLS AND HIS
EXPERIENCE. IN THE IN THE
AGENCY AND ITS SENSITIVITY TO
COMMUNITY AND STAND STRONG
SUPPORT OF HIS APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
THING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BAKER FIVE FOR JUST. HI
BRADFORD MICROBIOTA HI
CRITICIZING HI DALLY FIVE DODD
FIVE TO RAZA I EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. FIVE HER
TADO HI JONES FIVE KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION HI NEWMAN.
I NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF A HI CAN
AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROSS HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT HI WHAT
KIND OF SKI. HI WIENER AYE WILK
HI BY THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN SENATOR BATES. I'M
NOT ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF JENNIFER
RIORDAN FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT BOARD MISTER DAN OF
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS MANAGING
DIRECTOR FOR CAMBRIDGE
ASSOCIATES A GLOBAL INVESTMENT
FIRM AND CURRENTLY SERVES ON
THE INVESTMENT COMMITTEES FOR
THE MARIN COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND BROADWAY ANGELS
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH TENTH ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
YOU'RE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YEAH ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES AYE AYE
BAKER RIGHT HI FORGES. HI BRAD.
BRADFORD FIVE CABRERA HI
PROTESTING FIVE DOLLY. HI DODD
HI THERE ALSO FIVE EGGMAN I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
FIVE HERTZBERG FIVE HUESO AYE
AYE HURTADO AYE JONES FIVE CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LEYVA. HI
WIRE HI MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION
FIVE NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN HI TO
ALL THOSE HI CAN I PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
HI STERN HI NUMBER HI BY
CASSIDY HI WIENER. HI WILK I
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN SENATOR BATES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ISAP AS THEIR- FERRELL'S IN
STEVE NO FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION MISTER FERRELL
SERVES AS STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE AND MR KNOW IF
THE PUBLIC MEMBER THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH TENTH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER BATES.
SENATOR BAKER. THE BOOK
NOMINATIONS AND I'VE KNOWN
STEVE NO FOR MANY MANY YEARS
WHAT WE CAN DO A GREAT DEAL
EDUCATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT HIS NOMINATION THANK
YOU SENATOR BAKER FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES FIVE DECKER FIVE FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD. HI
CABALLERO HI COURTESY. CORTESE
I DALY AYE DODD. HI THERE ALSO
HI EGGMAN I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
FIVE GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO HI HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. HI LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE
MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN FIVE A
TOTAL OF BOTH. HI PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI WHAT KIND OF CITY HI WIENER.
I WILK AYE AYES THIRTY NINE
NINE ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
ON TO SENATE THIRD READING WE
WILL START WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR RUBIO ARE
YOU READY. AND I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG DAY
SENATOR RUBIO. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE PROBABLY 2% S. E. R.
TWENTY ONE WHICH HONORS THE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBURG. THIS RESOLUTION
ALSO PROCLAIMS MARCH FIFTEENTH
HER BIRTHDATE JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBURG DATE TODAY WE
CELEBRATE REMEMBER AND HONOR
JUSTICE GINSBURG FOR BEING A
VIBRANT GUARDIAN OF EQUALITY
FOR ALL. IT WAS JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO ON SEPTEMBER
EIGHTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THAT WE WERE DEVASTATED TO HEAR
OF HER PASSING AFTER A LONG
BATTLE WITH CANCER. ALTHOUGH
JUSTICE GINSBURG IS NOT WITH US
TODAY SHE LEFT A PROFOUND MARK
IN AMERICAN HISTORY AND THE
NATION IS DEEPLY INDEBTED TO
HER. SHE CERTAINLY HAS LEFT US
VERY PROUD IN THIS LEGISLATURE
THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE ONE OF MY FAVORITE QUOTES
FROM JUSTICE GINSBURG
PERMISSION TO READ. PLEASE
PROCEED. AS SHE ONCE SAID
WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE OVERALL HUMAN
RIGHTS AGENDA TRAINED ON THE
EQUITY OF DIGNITY AND ABILITY
TO LIVEIN FREEDOM ALL PEOPLE
SHOULD ENJOY AS WE CELEBRATE
WOMEN'S HISTORY. WE MUST ALWAYS
REMEMBER TO HIGHLIGHT WOMEN
THAT WERE TROWBRIDGE LASERS AND
SHOULDERSWE ALL STAND ON. THE
RECOGNIZING JUSTICE GINSBURG
IT'S OBVIOUS AND NECESSARY. SHE
SHAPED AMERICAN LAW FOR DECADES
IN THE COURTS AND HELP PAVE
PATH FOR CIVIL AND EQUAL RIGHTS
FOR WOMEN SHE LEAVES A LASTING
LEGACY. HER LANDMARK CASE
UNITED STATES VERSUS VIRGINIA.
AND THE GENDER SEGREGATION IN
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS AND SET THE
PRECEDENT FOR EVERY GENDER
EQUITY VICTORY THAT FOLLOWED.
SHE WAS A WOMAN OF JEWISH FAITH
WHO ENTERED GENDER AND
RELIGIOUS DISCRIMINATION THAT
THE NIGHT HER EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. HOWEVER SHE
OVERCAME THESE CHALLENGES AND
BROKE MANY BARRIERS HE
GRADUATED FIRST IN HER CLASS
FROM COLUMBIA LAW SCHOOL BECAME
THE FIRST FEMALE PROFESSOR
TURNED TENURE AT COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL. SERVED AS THE FIRST
FEMALE MEMBER OF THE HARVARD
LAW REVIEW AND COLUMBIA LAW
REVIEW AND LATER BECAME THE
SECOND WOMAN APPOINTED TO THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
THROUGH LITIGATION COMMUNITY
OUTREACH ADVOCACYAND PUBLIC
EDUCATION JUSTICE GINSBURG
EMPOWER ALL WOMEN. INCLUDING
WOMEN OF COLOR AND ALSO THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY WHO HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO GENDER BIAS AND WHO
FACE PERVASIVE BARRIERS FOR
QUALITY. SHE WORK TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE AND THEIR
FAMILIES CAN ENJOY THE BENEFITS
OF FULL EQUALITY. AND
PARTICIPATE IN EVERY SPHERE OF
SOCIETY TODAY WE RECOGNIZE AND
HONOR JUSTICE GINSBURG FOR HER
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION FOR
ALL. THANK YOU MEMBER AND I
RESPECT PLEASE ASK FOR NOT ABLE
THANK YOU CENTER ROOM MA'AM
DISCUSS AND OR DEBATE CENTER.
THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT. WHEN I
WAS IN LAW SCHOOL. I TOOK A TAX
CLASS IN ANYBODY'S TAKEN A TAX
CLASS AND LAW SCHOOL OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER COULD CERTAINLY
MAKE YOUR EYES BLEED. BUT
EITHER WAY- THE PROFESSOR OF
THIS TAX CLASS WAS- RETREAT
PETER GINSBURG'S HUSBAND. AND I
ENJOYED LEARNING AND- FROM HIM
WHEN I WAS THERE BUT WHAT
REALLY STOOD OUT. IS EVERY SO
OFTEN. AT THE END OF THE DAY
THERE WOULD BE. THIS PERSON
THAT WOULD COME ONTO CAMPUS.
AND SHE HAD A SLIGHT FRAME.
VERY SMALL VERY PETITE. AND
THAT OF COURSE WAS RECRUITER
GINSBURG COMING TO HAVE LUNCH
OR HAVE A SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT
WITH HER HUSBAND OVER THE LAW
SCHOOL. SHE WOULD WALK ON THE
CAMPUS. EVEN WITH HER SLIGHT
FRAME. SHE WAS A GIANT. AND
WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH HER
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHIES OR HER
LEGAL PHILOSOPHIES. I THINK
IT'S THEIR RESPECTIVE AT THIS
POINT SHE HAS TRULY MADE HER
MARK. AS A MEMBER OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF FOR HER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE JUDICIARY
AND FOR THAT WOULD CERTAINLY
HONOR ALL THAT SHE HAS ONE TO
IMPROVE HOW OUR LEGAL SYSTEM
WORKS. OUR EQUITY SYSTEM WORKS-
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY. I THINK
LAW IS AND WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
AND SO THAT I WANT TO APPLAUD-
THE AUTHOR OF THIS- THIS
MOTION- FOR THIS BILL- THE
SENATOR FROM BALDWIN PARK I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU
SENATOR GORGEOUS SENATOR TO
RUSSELL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION CELEBRATING OUR LATE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE BIRTHDAY.
DINNER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS ON
THE BENCH JUSTICE GINSBURG
GINSBURG DRAFT CRAFTED A LEGACY
THAT HELPED SHAPE OUR SOCIETY.
SO EVEN IF SHE WAS WRITING
DISSENTS AGAINST THE MAJORITY
DECISION AND SHE WOULD SAY. THE
DISSENTERS HOPE THAT THEY ARE
READY NOT FOR TODAY BUT FOR
TOMORROW AN EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
THE LEAD BETTER CASE.
ATTRIBUTED WERE INFLUENCING THE
LILLY LEDBETTER FAIR PAY ACT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT JUSTICE
GINSBURG ALSO HAD A LASTING
IMPACT ON IMMIGRANTS. INCLUDING
HELPING TO OVERTURN THE ATTEMPT
TO END THE DACA PROGRAM. VOTING
WITH THE MAJORITY TO OVERTURN
THE CONTROVERSIAL TWENTY TEN
ARIZONA IS BE TEN SEVENTY. THAT
ALLOWED OFFICERS TO DETAIN
ANYONE THEY SUSPECTED TO BE
UNDOCUMENTED. VOTED IN FAVOR OF
UPHOLDING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS FOR UNDOCUMENTED TO
CHALLENGE THEIR DETENTION IN
GOVERNMENT CUSTODY. JUSTICE
GINSBURG GINSBURG BEST PUT IT.
A MEANINGFUL LIFE MEANS LIVING
FOR ONE'S FAMILY AND ONE'S
COMMUNITY NOT FOR ONESELF THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS OF SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I TO RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
TWENTY ONE AUTHORED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK
WHICH MAKES TODAY MARCH
FIFTEENTH JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG DAY. RBG LIVED A
REMARKABLE LIFE ONE CENTERED ON
JUSTICE AND EQUITY WHICH IS NOT
TO SUPPOSED TO ACCOMPLISH ANY
OF THE AMAZING THING SHE WAS
KNOWN FOR. HER STORY IS A
TESTAMENT TO DEFYING THE ODDS
GROWING UP FEMALE AND JEWISH
AND WORKING CLASS WHEN BEING AT
A TIME WHEN COULD BE ANY ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WITH AN IMPEDIMENT
TO SUCCESS. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN PARK LAID OUT MANY OF
THE REMARKABLE GLASS CEILING
SHATTERING ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
HER CAREER I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THROUGH THAT TIME SHE
NEVER LOST SIGHT OF OUR VALUES.
SHE FOUGHT TIRELESSLY
RELENTLESSLY FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
WHETHER FOR WOMEN FOR RACIAL
MINORITIES OR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY WHETHER AS A YOUNG
LAWYER OR WHILE ON THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE KIMBER BEGINS
BURKE FOUGHT AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND SOUGHT TO
EMPOWER MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES IN THIS COUNTRY.
SHE CREATED BETTER WORLD FOR US
AND FOR OUR CHILDREN AND SHE
BLAZED A TRAIL FOR MILLIONS OF
YOUNG WOMEN AND GIRLS INCLUDING
MY EIGHT YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AND
ME. TO FOLLOW. NOW AFTER HER
DAY WE'VE BEEN FROM THE FRUITS
OF HER LABOR BUT HER LEGACY
WILL CONTINUE TO INSPIRE US.
MANY HAVE SAID MAY HER MEMORY
BE A BLESSING AND A REVOLUTION.
AND I WANT TO JUST PAUSE ON
THIS BECAUSE IT GOES TO THE
HEART OF HOW REMEMBRANCES
ACTIVE AND NOT PASSIVE. IF WE
WANT TO TRULY HONOR THE LEGACY
OF THE NOTORIOUS RBG. WE MUST
ACTIVELY FIGHT FOR PROGRESS
INEQUALITY. EVEN WHEN.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE ODDS SEEM
STACKED AGAINST US THAT IS THE
BEST WAY TO HONOR THE LIFE.
WITH THAT I ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION BUT ALSO TO FIGHT ON
FOR HER MEMORY AND HER LEGACY
MAY HER MEMORY BE A BLESSING
AND A REVOLUTION. THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
CENTER MELINDA'S. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT LAYS IN GERMAN
I RISE TODAY ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
S. C. R. TWENTY ONE- REPEATER
GINSBURG WAS INDEED A GIANT
AMONG A SEA OF MEN. AND SHE
PAVE THE WAY FOR MANY MANY
WOMEN TO FOLLOW HER AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT MY OWN NIECE
ISABELLA WAS ABLE TO GO TO THE
VIRGINIA MILITARY INSTITUTE.
BECAUSE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
HELP MAKE THAT POSSIBLE SO I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO HER
CONTRIBUTIONS IN FACT- WHEN I
WAS IN THE NAVY I CAN RECALL.
MORNING TO FLY- ABOARD
RECONNAISSANCE AIRCRAFT AND
BEING TOLD I COULD NOT DO THAT
BECAUSE- WOMEN JUST WEREN'T
ALLOWED TO DO THAT YET IT WAS
ONLY THE MEN AND I WAS VERY
PUZZLED BY THAT I THOUGHT WELL
I CAN I CAN MEET THE SAME
PHYSICAL REQUIREMENTS I CAN
COMPLETE SAME TRAINING WHAT DO
YOU MEAN I CAN'T DO THIS- IT
TAKES PERSISTENCE IN PUSHING.
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT I DID.
AND WAS ABLE TO IN FACT- BE
ABLE TO FIND THOSE AIRCRAFT
BUT- IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S PEOPLE
LIKE REPORTER GINSBURG TO
REALLY. GIVES PEOPLE LIKE ME
AND EVERYONE EVERY OTHER WOMAN
WHO COMES AFTER HEARD KIND OF
THE- YOU KNOW THE COURAGE TO
PUSH BACK AND SAY NO. I DON'T
THINK SO I THINK THIS OUGHT TO
BE AN OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE. TO
EVERYONE WHO CAN MEET THE
STANDARDS SO I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS YEAR TWENTY ONE TODAY.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR RUBIO FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AND ASK FR YOUR ABOUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
MELINDA'S CENTER EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MINISTER AND
MEMBERS. I TO RISE ON BEHALF OF
A RBG DAY- I THINK FOR ANY OF
US WHO ARE IN THIS CHAMBER AND
SHE HAS IMPACTED ALL OF OUR
LIVES WHEN I THINK OF ANYONE
WHO SERVED IN THE MILITARY.
ESPECIALLY WAS GONE AND ABLE TO
GO TO THE ACADEMY'S THE TO KNOW
THAT SHE PAVE THE WAY FOR THAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT I. ALWAYS
THINK ABOUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT
HER IS- THE QUOTE I'M WEARING
ON MY ON MY TO MY MASTER SAYS
BELIEVE IN THE- THANK FOR THE
THINGS YOU BELIEVE IN. BUT DO
IT IN A WAY THAT OTHERS WILL
COME ALONG AND I REFLECT ON
HER. HER FRIENDSHIP. WITH THAT
SOMEBODY WHO SHE'D
DIAMETRICALLY WAS OPPOSED TO ON
ISSUES ON POLICY. AND MISTER
JUSTICE SCALIA. BUT THEY WERE
ABLE TO FORGE A FRIENDSHIP IN
SPITE OF THAT AND I HOPE WE CAN
ALL FOLLOW. AND THAT TOO THAT
EVEN WHEN WE DISSENT. EVEN WHEN
OUR VOICES AND THE MINORITY.
THAT IT STILL COUNTS AND WE
STILL FIND WAYS TO COME
TOGETHER AS SHE DID. I WORK FOR
THE BEST OF THIS NATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MARILYN AND ACTUALLY- THE GOOD
FURNITURE- WE JUST SPOKE AND I.
CAN'T REMEMBER WHERE YOU'RE
FROM. ACTUALLY COVERED MY
POINTS BUT I WANTED TO MENTION
THAT ARE YOU STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS. AND ARE
ACTUALLY- IN HONOR OF. THOSE- I
GATHER MY THOUGHTS FOR A MINUTE
HI FORGET EMOTIONAL ENOUGH. I
THINK I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE COURAGE
THAT SHE SHOWED ARE WHILE MANY
OF US DIDN'T AGREE WITH ALL AND
EVERYTHING THAT SHE STOOD FOR
AN INVENTION SHE HAD THE
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD AND
SPEAK UP. AND TAKE ON ISSUES
THAT WERE NOT POPULAR AT THE
TIME HI TO ME THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT THING TO REFLECT ON
AS WE LOOK AT THAT AS AT TODAY
WITH HER ONE OF HER CLOSEST
FRIENDS- IN THE JUDICIAL RAM
WITH ANTON SCALIA. WITH WHOM
SHE HAD DISAGREEMENTS BUT
RESPECTFUL DISAGREEMENTS AND
WAS ABLE TO PULL TOGETHER A
WITH HIM A RESPECT FOR BOTH
SIDES OF AN ISSUE AND THAT
STANDS OUT ESPECIALLY IN THESE
TIMES WHEN WE SEE OUR THE
CONTENTION ON THAT GOES ON. ALL
WITH SOMEONE WITH SOME
DIFFERENT BELIEFS AND SOME OF
THE- REALLY ACRIMONIOUS
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE ARE HEARING
A LOT IN OUR STATE CAPITOL SO
I'D LIKE US TO REMEMBER THAT
SHE FOUND AWAY SHE SAID A PATH
THAT WE COULD ALL FOLLOW TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE. BUT
RETAIN THE FRIENDSHIPS AND THE
RESPECT FOR HUMAN KIND BECAUSE
WE'RE ALL HERE TO WORK ON THE
SAME ISSUES- IN THE BETTERMENT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
CERTAINLY OUR NATION AND KEEP
IT- PULL FOR THE PRESENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU SENATOR BATES
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU RUN
A RED- RISE TO AS VICE. OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A ZERO TWENTY ONE.
AM PROUD- THAT ALL OF MY JEWISH
CAUCUS SENATE COLLEAGUES ARE CO
AUTHORS OF THIS RESOLUTION. AT
THIS PAST YEAR WE LOST ASSIST
GINSBURG. ON THE EVE OF ROSADA
THE START OF OUR HIGH HOLIDAYS.
AND AT THE START OF OUR YEAR-
IT WAS A STRANGE AND DIFFICULT
HIGH WHOLE HOLIDAYS GIVEN
COVERED RESTRICTIONS. DURING
WHICH MANY OF US COULD NOT
GATHER AS A COMMUNITY. THE NEWS
OF JUSTICE GINSBURG PASSING. AS
WE ENTER THE HOLIDAY WAS
ESPECIALLY DEVASTATED.
DEVASTATED AS ONLY THE SECOND
WOMAN AND THE FIRST JEWISH
WOMAN TO SERVE. ON THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE GINSBURG'S LIFE
AND LEGACY. I REMAIN A CITING
EXAMPLE OF JEWISH PERSEVERANCE.
AND MORAL LEADERSHIP. WELL WE
ARE AND PROUD OF HER AS LEADING-
ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN. AND
PROGRESSIVE- PROGRESSIVE-
PRINCIPLES. WERE PARTICULARLY
PROUD THAT JUSTICE GINSBURG
REGULARLY ATTRIBUTED THOSE
VALUES. TO HER JEWISH FAITH. IN
FACT THAT OUR CONFIRMATION
HEARING. WHEN SHE WAS
QUESTIONED ABOUT HOW HER GENDER
EQUALITY WORK MIGHT SENSITIZE
HER TO RACIAL DISCRIMINATION.
JUSTICE GINSBURG RESPONDED
RESPONDED QUOTE ONE COULDN'T
HELP BUT BE SENSITIVE TO
DISCRIMINATION LIVING AS A JEW
IN AMERICA AND QUOTE. HERMAS IS
A HOMEOWNER CHAMBER DOOR- AND
SHE QUOTED- THE TORAH ON HER
DOOR. IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX-
JUSTICE GINSBURG AND A NEW YORK
TIMES OP ED ENTITLED WHAT BEING
JEWISH MEANS TO ME. TENNESSEE
ROADS QUOTE I AM A JUDGE
FOREIGN REYES AND PROUD OF
BEING A JEW THE DEMAND FOR
JUSTICE RUNS THROUGH THE
ENTIRETY OF THE JEWISH
TRADITION. I HOPE IN MY YEARS
ON THE BENCH OF THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES I
WILL HAVE THE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE TO REMAIN CONSTANT IN
THE SERVICE ABOUT THE MAN'S. BY
JUSTICE GINSBURG ABSOLUTELY-
EMBODIED- THE COR- PRINCIPLE OF
TIKKUN OLAM IN JUDAISM HEALING
THE WORLD WE MOURN HER WE MISS
HER I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER. SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER RUBIO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR ALL YOUR KIND WORDS
ON HER BEHALF AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK GOD MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS FLOOR FOR. WEARING HER-
ICONIC COLOR IN HONOR OF HER
BIRTHDAY AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOR THIS
VOTE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED- TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE. CENTER GROVE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE REFER.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR GROWTH RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S MILITARY HISTORY WEEK
CENTER GROVE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT S. R. THIRTEEN WHICH
COMMEMORATES. THIS WEEK IS
MARCH FOURTEENTH THE TWENTIETH
AS WOMEN IN HISTORY- WOMEN'S
MILITARY HISTORY WEEK. OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM HAVE SERVED IN THE IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN WARS CURRENTLY
THERE ARE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION AMAZING BRAVE WOMEN
SERVING IN THE ARMED FORCES OF
THE UNITED STATES AND MORE THAN
NINE THOUSAND. FEMALE TROOPS
EVER COMBAT ACTION GROUPS-
COMBAT ACTION BADGES DURING
COMBAT OPERATIONS AND DURING
THE IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN WARS.
THE HISTORY OF WOMEN IN OUR
MILITARY IS FILLED WITH
INCREDIBLE STORIES OF BRAVERY
ACHIEVEMENT. AND LONG BEFORE
WOMEN WERE FULLY EVEN
INTEGRATED INTO THE ARMED
FORCES. IN NINETEEN SKEWS ME IN
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT DEBORAH
SAMPSON DISGUISED HERSELF AS A
MAN TO BRIEFLY SERVED IN THE
CONTINENTAL ARMY. A FORMER
SLAVE KATHY WILLIAMS CONCEALED
HER IDENTITY AND SERVED AS THE
ONLY RECORDED WOMAN BUFFALO
SOLDIER. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE SERGEANT LEE ANN HESTER
BECAME THE FIRST FEMALE UNITED
STATES ARMY. MILITARY VETERAN
OR MILITARY OFFICER TO EARN THE
SILVER STAR IN A DIRECT COMBAT
ACTION. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
GENERAL M. E. DEN DEN WHERE HE
BECAME THE FIRST FEMALE FOUR
STAR GENERAL IN MILITARY
HISTORY AND JUST LAST MONTH
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD CALIFORNIA
MARINE CORPORAL- JULIANA YUCCA
VICK BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN TO
GRADUATE FROM THE HIGH POWERED
CIRCUITS COURSE TO TAKE ON THE
COMBAT ARTILLERY LEADERSHIP
ROLE. THE STORY SERVE AS A
TESTAMENT TO THE HURDLES OF
WOMEN IN MILITARY THEY HAVE
OVERCOME THAT THEY'VE OVER CAN
TO PROVE THAT THEY TOO CAN
SELFLESSLY SERVE OUR NATION AND
DEFEND OUR FREEDOMS THAT WE
ENJOY TODAY. THE FIRST FEMALE
VETERAN ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
IT'S MY DISTINCT HONOR TO
PRESENT S. R. THIRTEEN ALONG
WITH TWO OTHER FEMALE VETERANS
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY THAT
WE'VE HAD THREE FEMALE SENATORS
THAT HAVE BEEN SERVING IN THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY.
SENATORS MELENDEZ AND SENATOR
EGGMAN I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
IN RECOGNIZING WOMEN'S MILITARY
HISTORY WEEK IN HONORING OUR
WOMEN WARRIORS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER GROVE DISCUSSION.
AND DEBATE SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE
TODAY TO HONOR THE WOMEN WHO
ARE SERVING IN THE MILITARY
RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK. THE
WOMEN WHO HAVE RETIRED WITH
HONOR AND IGNITY AND PRIDE IN
THEIR MILITARY SERVICE AND I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THESE WOMEN WHO HAVE GIVEN SO
MUCH TO OUR GREAT NATION FIRST
OFF GENERAL LAURIE GENE
ROBINSON RETIRED COMMANDER OF
THE UNITED STATES NORTHERN
COMMAND. AND COMMANDER OF THE
NORTH AMERICAN AEROSPACE
DEFENSE COMMAND UNTIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SHE WAS THE FIRST
FEMALE OFFICER IN THE HISTORY
OF UNITED STATES ARMED FORCES
REPRIMAND A MAJOR UNIFIED
COMBAT. UNIT ALSO UNITED STATES
AIR FORCE GENERAL JACK KEANE
BAND OVER STE THE ONLY ACTIVE
DUTY WOMAN TO CURRENTLY HOLD
THE RANK OF A FOUR STAR
GENERAL. THE MILITARY HIGHEST.
NOMINATED INDIVIDUAL FOUR STAR
GENERAL AND SHE WAS NOMINATED
TO HEAD THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMAND. ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THREE STAR GENERAL
LAURA RICHARDSON NOMINATED TO
LEAD SOUTHERN COMMAND WHICH
COVERS CENTRAL AND LATIN
AMERICA SHE WILL ALSO RECEIVE
HER FOURTH STORE THE HIGHEST
RANKING IN THE MILITARY. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO. COMMENT ABOUT
CAPTAIN CHRISTIAN CHRIST AND
FIRST LIEUTENANT SHE HAVER
FIRST FEMALE OFFICER GRADUATES
OF THE ARMY RANGER SCHOOL AT
FORT BENNING ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST SCHOOLS IN THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY. AND FINALLY
THE ENLISTED RANKS STAFF
SERGEANT AMANDA KELLY THE FIRST
ENLISTED FEMALE GRADUATE OF THE
ARMY RANGER COURSE FORT BENNING
GEORGIA ALL SERVING WITH
DIGNITY AND HONOR FOR OUR GREAT
COUNTRY AND I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SR THIRTEEN THANK
YOU TANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO HONOR ALL THE WOMEN
THAT HAVE SERVED AND ALL THOSE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SERVING IN.
PARTICULAR I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK OUR CALL FOR ON
THIS FLOOR WHO HAVE SERVED I
AND JOB I KNOW THE CHALLENGES
OF SOME OF THE FAMILY SPACES
SPECIALLY- WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE FAR AWAY SO I'LL TAKE A
MOMENT JUST TO HONOR MY- SISTER
IN LAW WHO IS CURRENTLY SERVING
IN GERMANY. AND WHO HAD A BABY.
AND DIE AND JUST THINK
EVERYONE- THEIR FAMILIES AND
EVERYONE WHO'S ALLOWED THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS TO SEARCH
THINKING. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IS TO IS-
THERE IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION
WE WILL PROVIDE THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
THEN I IS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR EGGMAN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. PASS ON
FILE. PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD.
PARDON ME THAT IS MY FAULT I
LOOKED AT ONE NAME AND READ THE
WRONG THING FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT CENTER ATKINS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION NINETEEN BY SENATOR
ATKINS OF RELATIVE TO THE
ELECTION OF MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
CENTER ATKINS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT HI AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO TODAY SO I
RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION NINETEEN. WHICHAPPOINT SENATOR COM LARGER TO
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE TO
REPLACE OUR MAJORITY LEADER
SENATOR HERTZBERG. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. MAYBE I SHOULD ADD WITH
THANKS TO THE MAJORITY LEADER
FOR FILLING THAT POSITION WHILE
WE AWAITED. THE SPECIAL
ELECTION MR MAJORITY LEADER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
ATKINS MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
I BAKER I FORGES AYE BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO HI COURTESY HI
DALLY HI DODD.HI TERRAZZA FIVE
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
BY GROWTH HI HERTZBERG. FIVE
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ AYE MAN AYE
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. FIVE CONTROL
OF BOTH I PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW
SKI HI WIENER. HI WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE NEWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WHICH IS
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE THAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE
WILL START WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY THREE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND AFTER LEADING TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS A
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. CENTERS CAN. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS YES NOW THE
MY DESIGN- WE HEARD. AB EIGHTY
THREE AND PASSED IT IN THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING IT IS THE CLEAN UP. FOR
OUR PREVIOUSLY PASSED SB NINETY
FOUR. IN THAT IT ADDS. A SET
OF- ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
LICENSES TO OUR FEE WAIVERS FOR
LICENSEES THAT WERE CONTAINED
IN SB NINETY FOUR SO WHAT IT
DOES IS PROVIDE FEE WAIVERS FOR
OUR SMALL BREWERS ARE SMALL
WINERIES AND OUR CRAFT
DISTILLERS IT'S THREE MILLION
IN- GENERAL FUND IS
APPROPRIATED IN THIS BACK BILL
TO COVER THESE WAIVERS IT
IMPACTS APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
LICENSEES. AND THE LICENSES ARE
ACTIVE FOR TWO YEARS AND THE
WAIVER COVERS TWO YEARS WHICH
IS ONE LICENSING CYCLE IN WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THE CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SANDERS CAN I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BECKER AYE FORTUS HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A- HI COURTESY
HI DALLY I DODD. HI THE RAZA HI
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG
FIVE WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI WIRE FIVE MELENDEZ
FIVE MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
BY A SHOW OF THE- FIVE TEN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER HI
CASKEY HI WIENER. HI WILK HI.
FIVE THREE NINE ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACTUAL LEADING TO COVERED
RELIEF AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. THANK YOU SEE
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND- MEMBERS AB
EIGHTY EIGHT IS TO CLEAN UP TO
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
TRAILER BILL WHICH WE PASSED
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO. AND THE
MAJOR COMPONENTS OF THE BILL
ARE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE INCLUDED
IN THE PRIOR FEDERAL STIMULUS
WE ARE MAKING THIS CONFORM SO
THAT GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PAYMENTS AND GOLDEN STATE GRANT
PAYMENTS ARE EXEMPTED FROM
GARNISHMENT ORDERS. AND ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS IT CLARIFIES
THAT A QUALIFIED RECIPIENT DOES
NOT INCLUDE ANY INDIVIDUAL THAT
IS CLAIMED AS A DEPENDENT AND
IT EXCLUDES THE OTHER PROVISION
THE BILL IS THAT IT EXCLUDES
GOLDEN STATE GRANT PAYMENTS
FROM GROSS INCOME SIMILAR TO
EXISTING LAW THAT EXCLUDES
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PAYMENTS
FROM THAT PROVISION. MAKES A
FEW OTHER TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND WITHOUT
MEMBERS I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND
THIS WAS ALSO HEARD TODAY IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND APPROVED
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI HOW ARE TO LETTER I
ATKINS. ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER
HI FORGES. BRADFORD HI CABRERA
HI PROTESTING HI DOLLY. DODD HI
TO RAZA I EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI TADA I JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. I TRIED BOTH.
HI CAN AYE PORTANTINO HI ROTH
HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI MY COUNTY HI
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
FORGES. DALLY GROWTH. JONES.
MELENDEZ NIELSEN. FIVE THREE
TWO NINE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR HUESO.
MEMBERS SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS IS MADE IN
UPON A GERMAN OF THE SENATE
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS
THANK YOU SIR HUESO MEMBERSWE
ARE RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND THIS WILL BE
THE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR GERMAN
IN MEMORIES WE HAVE THREE TODAY
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR PORTANTINO. COLLEAGUES
TODAY I RISE TO IN GERMAN IN
THE MEMORY OF BETTY SANFORD.
WHO PASSED AWAY AT NINETY YEARS.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF BETTY SANFORD WHO
PASSED AWAY AT NINETY YEARS
YOUNG. BUT HE WAS BEST KNOWN
FOR HER ACTIVISM IN SUPPORT OF
ALL THINGS ROUND MINE ROAD VIA
THE CITY WERE SHE WAS BORN AND
SPENT HER ENTIRE LIFE. HE
SERVED ON MORE COMMUNITY
COMMITTEES AND I HAVE TIME TO
MENTION AND HER LEGACY IS
VISIBLE THROUGH THE ENTIRE
TOWN. BUT MOST NOTABLY. WITH
HER WORK ON THE MONROVIA
UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD AND AS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE FOOTHILL
UNITY CENTER. HE WAS WELL
RESPECTED AND RIGHTFULLY NAMED
A PILLAR OF THE COMMUNITY.
DIVERSITY IN ELECTED
REPRESENTATION WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO BETTY SHE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO FIGHT SOCIAL
INJUSTICES AND HELP ELECTED
MIMI MINSI AND BOB BARTLETT THE
LEGENDARY BOB BARTLETT.
ARMENIAN BOB BECAME THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN ELECTED TO
OFFICE IN MONROVIA. BUT HE
WORKED HARD IN THE NUCLEAR
FREEZE MOVEMENT WHEN AL GORE
LED THE FIRST CLIMATE CHANGE
CONFERENCE IN BRAZIL. BETTY
WENT TO BRAZIL AND WAS THERE
SHE ENJOYED TRAVELING ENGROSS
YOURSELF IN OTHER CULTURES AND
LOVED READING NON FICTION I SHE
WAS AN AVID LEARNER. HER CHEEK
MENTION HONORS WERE MANY BUT
OUR HIGHEST HONOR WAS BEING
MOTHER TO RANDY LESLIE AND
KEVIN STANFORD AND THE
GRANDMOTHER OF SARA BECKER
ALICIA AND MIA. AND HER NEWEST
GRANDCHILD MOLLY MASON AND
MERRILL. HE SOMEONE WHOSE CALL
I ALWAYS TOOK. AN WHO ENGAGED
IN LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE AND
NATIONAL ISSUES WITH A PASSION
AND A COMMITMENT AND I WILL
MISS BETTY SANFORD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FOR US SO
WE CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
HERS. SENATOR PAM. CENTERS
TODAY I RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART
TO TURN MEMORY OF SIMON CHAN
AND I KIND OF OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY PASSED AWAY OF COVERT
NINETEEN. YOU MIGHT JUST KNOW
HIM AS SIMON AND IF YOU'VE
WORKED IN SACRAMENTO POLITICS
IN THE LAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS
YOU CERTAINLY KNOW OF HIS BAR
SILENCE ON SIXTEENTH STREET.
SIMON EMIGRATED FROM CHINA TO
THE UNITED STATES IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. AFTER PRINT
THE C. UNDER FRANK FAT'S FOR
DECADES EVEN FILLED HIS
AMERICAN DREAM AND OPEN SCIENCE
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THAT
TIME THE CITY AROUND SIMON SAYS
UNDERGONE CHANGE AFTER CHANGE
GENERATIONS OF POLITICIANS
STAFFERS THE STATE WORKERS HAVE
COME AND GONE. BUT SIMON'S BAR
IN SIMON AND SELF HAVE BEEN A
CONSTANT. I NEVER CHANGED AND
FOR SO MANY OF US THAT WAS A
COMFORT. WE ALWAYS KNEW WHAT WE
WOULD FIND WHEN WE WALKED
THROUGH THE DOOR AT SIMON'S
INCLUSIVE BAR THE BEARS CHINO
RED BOOTS THE PHOTOS ON THE
WALLS. THE FRIENDS HE MOST
CERTAINLY WOULD RUN INTO AN OF
COURSE SIMON HIMSELF BEHIND THE
BAR WITH AN INFECTIOUS SMILE
SHARING A LAUGH WITH A PATRON.
FOR MANY OF US SIMON'S
FRIENDSHIP IS IRREPLACEABLE.
AND WHETHER IT WAS HIS
INTENTION OR NOT HIS LEGACY
WILL LIVE ON IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICS FOR YEARS TO COME. WE
WANNA SHARE CONDOLENCES WITH
SIMON CHAN'S FAMILY AND LET
THEM KNOW THAT HE WILL BE
DEEPLY MISSED AND THANK HIM FOR
SOMENORMA'S IMPACT HE'S MADE
ON OUR COMMUNITY. I KNOW THAT
HIS LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO
LIVE ON AS WE ALL RAISE A GLASS
AND TOAST. AND MEMORY TO SIMON
I ASKED WE TURNED IN HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER PAN
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. BETTER PRO TEM
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ONE OF SAN DIEGO'S
FINEST GEORGE MURPHY WHO PASSED
AWAY ON NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY BORN IN PERU
INDIA GEORGE KNEW FROM A YOUNG
AGE THAT FARM LIFE DID NOT
QUITE SUIT HIM HE WOULD FOLLOW
HIS OWN PATH IN THE TEACHING
AND COUNSELING BY WAY OF BALL
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN. TIRED
OF HIS NATIVE MIDWEST COLD
WINTERS HE TRADED IN THE GREAT
LAKES FOR THE PACIFIC SHORE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. THE DAY
HE ARRIVED ON THE WEST COAST
SHOULD BE DOCUMENTED IN SAN
DIEGO'S HISTORY BOOKS BECAUSE
THE MARK HE MADE ON OUR CITY.
WELL AS LONG PASSED HIS
PASSING. OVER THE COURSE OF
FIVE DECADES GEORGE FOUND THE
TIME TO ESTABLISH THE ADULT
CAREER GUIDANCE CENTER AT
GROSSMONT COLLEGE HE HELPED
FOUND CLEAR MARKET COLLEGE.
WHERE HE WORKED AS A COUNSELOR
AND PROGRAM COORDINATOR. HE
BECAME A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CENTER OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY
CENTER. THE SAN DIEGO
DEMOCRATIC CLUB THE LAND OUR
CATS IN OUR WHICH WAS OUR LOCAL
LGBTQ HISTORICAL ARCHIVE. ALL
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
GEORGE HELPED CREATE HOLD
PROMINENCE IN OUR CITY. I HAVE
DONE MUCH TO SERVE OUR
NEIGHBORS BUT HE DIDN'T STOP
THERE. GEORGE DEDICATED HIMSELF
TO SERVING ON VARIOUS BOARDS AT
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HE
HELPED FOUND HE VOLUNTEERED AT
THE METROPOLITAN COMMUNITY
CHURCH OF SAN DIEGO. HE HELPED
ESTABLISH THE SAN DIEGO AIDS
PROJECT HE SERVED ON SAN
DIEGO'S FIRST DAY CRISIS
HOTLINE. AND WAS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF HIS ICONIC BELOVED
NEIGHBORHOOD SHOULD BEACH. AND
THAT'S JUST THE READER'S DIGEST
VERSION. LOOKING THROUGH THE
LONG LIST OF ALL HE
ACCOMPLISHED. I'VE BECOME
CONVINCED HE MUST HAVE CRACKED
THE CODE ON HOW TO BE A TWO OR
THREE PLACES AT ONCE. ANY MUST
HAVE SINGLE HANDEDLY KEPT OB
BEANS COFFEE ROASTERS IN
BUSINESS. BEYOND THE GREAT WORK
GEORGE DID TO GIVE BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITY HE WILL BE REMEMBERED
BY ALL WHO HAD THE GREAT
FORTUNE TO KNOW HIM. AS A
GENTLE AND HUMBLE SOUL WHOSE
CARE FOR OTHERS RAN DEEPER THAN
THE PACIFIC OCEAN I ASK THAT
YOU JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF GEORGE MURPHY. THANK
YOU CENTER ATKINS PLEASE MAKE
SURE TO BRING HIS GOING FORWARD
SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
RUBIO. I PLEASE BRIEFLY ASKED
THAT THE LADIES OF THIS CHAMBER
THEY CAN STAY FOR AN APPROVED
VOLATILE. A GROUP PHOTO WHAT
THEIR COLLARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO IF THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS. ADAM PRO TEM
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU THANK ALL
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE WORK
TODAY TYPICALLY I WOULD DO THIS
AFTER THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW IN ADVANCE
WE HAVE TWO BIRTHDAYS THAT I'M
AWARE OF AT LEAST COMING UP
THIS WEEK. AND TOMORROW WE WILL
CELEBRATE OUR GOOD TO US
REPUBLICAN LEADERS BIRTHDAY AND
THEN ON THURSDAY WE WILL
CELEBRATE OUR FORMER REPUBLICAN
LEADERS BIRTHDAY SO- MRS
SENATORS WELCOMED GROW FAT I
HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT WEEK AND
I HOPE YOUR COLLEAGUES MAKE
SURE TO REACH OUT TO YOU AND
EXPRESS THEIR WELL WISHES AND
WITH THAT MADAM PRESIDENT. WE
ARE SCHEDULED FOR THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION ON THURSDAY MARCH
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT
NINE AM. THANK YOU CENTER
ACTIONS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
AGREE RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM. MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT
REST OF THE DAY.